so as the as the last panel clearly
indicated these are exciting times in
architecture and in life this is a fact
that that is not lost on students of
architecture today with a rapid in your
total adoption of digital drawing and
it's increasingly sophisticated
permutations by practice and education
alike
the contemporary architect commands the
most powerful analytic production and
representation tools arguably in history
in an economy of sustained uncertainty a
single architect or a small cohort of
architects are able to produce what in
earlier times might have taken an entire
office of many many people to produce
and with the distance between design and
fabrication shrinking the architect it's
arguably strong has a stronger influence
in the physical product that he or she
designs than ever before and yet as so
many speakers have mentioned due to the
alluring potency the efficiency in the
ubiquity of contemporary drawing tools
creativity is as often unwittingly
impeded by processing power design
obfuscated by image and knowledge
supplanted by information as has been
the case throughout the weekend the
final panel entitled the critical act
assembles a group of four renowned
practitioners who are all distinguished
educators despite working in diverse
methods each has made a deliberate and
dramatic use of drawing in their
practice and in so doing has established
an unmistakable signature to their work
following the last of this panelists
presentations the Yale School of
Architecture critic Sunil bald will
moderate a discussion which we hope will
provoke lively conversation and
entertain your questions at the end of
that and I'm sorry and then and then
immediately thereafter Mario carbo who
is the Vincent Scully a visiting
professor of architectural history here
at the Yale School of Architecture will
deliver a concluding address due to due
to the knee
to change the tapes in our audio-visual
recording we're gonna be taking a
10-minute technical break following the
third speaker Greg Lin but we will
resume immediately thereafter and and
proceed all the way through
Mario Karpos talk and recess upstairs
for a reception to conclude the
symposium so I'd like to introduce our
first speaker of the afternoon
Preston Scott Cohen Preston Scott Cohen
is the chair and Gerald M McHugh
professor of architecture at the
Graduate School of Design at Harvard
University and emerging College in
Boston
he is the principal of the firm Preston
Scott Cohen Inc in Cambridge
Massachusetts with projects of diverse
scales and types including houses
educational facilities cultural
institutions and urban designs he is the
author of contested symmetries and other
predicaments in architecture and the
forthcoming museum as genealogy the
return of nature co-edited with Erica
Nijinsky and the hidden core of
architecture a collection of theoretical
essays ladies and gentlemen Preston
Scott Cohen Thank You Victor and I'm
sorry George
I meant also the faint Victor both of
you and Dean Stern thank you so much for
having me from the University of the
North okay so rather than to proceed
with the conjecture that the most
radical consequence of computation has
been the displacement of drawing as we
had known it it seemed to me to be more
important today to assess whether or not
other developments displaced drawing
prior to the computer and to understand
what these mean for the most persistent
forms of representation and architecture
to this day it is useful first to make a
few observations about drawing we should
distinguish drawing as a medium of
communication or picture making from
drawing as geometric means to produce
forms and thereby to serve as an
instrument with which to define and
construct the architectural project
interestingly much of architecture even
its plans and sections has been
conceived the way pictures are directly
without the demanding regulatory
principles and constraints of geometry
and yet plans in particular imply
projection the enactment of extrusion
and sectioning thus it is important to
look back and discover the way drawing
as a geometric tool theoretically
redefined the convention of
architectural representation if we go
all the way back to the origins of
representation we see that early planned
drawing was executed directly at
full-scale gothic buildings were drawn
on the ground with ropes and what did
the scaled plan drawing the plan drawn
with a stylus on wax tablets or
parchment represent it represented
neither the ropes on the ground nor the
idea that the lines would extrude there
was no projective implication the plan
was already on the surface it was all
about allocating areas on the ground in
short architectural drawing was not
originally related to geometry only
later with perspective a foundational a
foundational element in projective
geometry become considered to be an
advanced form of drawing what it will
focus on now and what is perhaps most
important for the role that projection
as opposed to picture drawing plays and
architecture is the foundational
principle as I said of perspective
projection but in particular sectioning
I would like to argue that with
perspective came a profound redefinition
of what a plan is there is a world of
difference between pre perspective plan
and the plant after perspective from
then on plans are implicitly derived
from cutting through as opposed to
drawing upon something and this is what
makes them so much life today it was
during the Renaissance of course that we
actually saw the perspectives the
principles excuse me a perspective
formalized the demand for realism and
the Alliance of mathematics and nature
motivated the invention projection is a
of course a transference of
three-dimensional points and space to a
flat surface it translates
3d form to flatness and the rays of
light passing through points meet in one
the eye which interestingly projective
Li is coincidental with the vanishing
point a slicing plane and this is what
interests me most of course is like a
section cut through these rays and it
produces the matrix of points on a
surface which is a section and
ultimately a picture plane and these
points when linked to one another create
a projection of a scene in the 17th
century this changed and what occurred
is a description that cars brings into
correspondence the representation of
objects and the illusory
distortion of these according to the
idea of perspective this is dey's org
who combines the sectioning of solids
with perspective representation and in
here we see that he has brought these
two techniques together the orthogonal
and the conic projection the parallel
excuse me and the conic and in this way
the two finally are joined and thus we
have before us a situation in which we
cannot distinguish between the illusory
the picture the object the section it's
all in one system and so one could say
with all of this behind us the question
of the conference today could be rather
than is drawing dead could it could it
be that the section killed drawing I
would say theoretically yes the section
did do that and practically no or not
considerably so until considerably later
before during and after the age of four
active and section buildings were
designed and drawn in two dimensions
both in elevations and in section and
were assumed to extrude but only
empirically not by projective means with
the arrival of paper of course and with
Rafael's recommendation around 1850
eighteen
I'm sorry fifteen eighteen the plan is
accompanied by the representation of its
elevation but indirectly depicted as a
pictorial elevation showing two sides at
once the projective techniques were only
used to pictorially represent
preconceived ideas or were used by the
gill guilds for the purpose of
constructing three-dimensional
idiosyncratic shapes units of
construction projection then was
synonymous with stereo dami stone
cutting now something very interesting
happens in a case like this where the
plan is built out by perspective by
Bramante in a church that could not be
realized fully its plan owing to the
fact that a street ran behind the church
and so perspective is deployed in an
illusory way again but in this case to
bring about the impression of a
centralized plan compressed back to the
section in this sense finally
perspective becomes a means to build the
very plan that we understand the section
cutting implies when we think through
the principle from its origin probably
the most important implication and the
analogy between section thinking and
perspective is that they share the idea
that the object represented as is in
some sense a complete whole an entirely
new way of thinking that appears but
first time in the Renaissance
architecture is preconceived following
from it are the plans and perspectives
that are cut projected and cut again and
yet this idea was not widely practiced
or understood a rare exception came in
1515 with Peru see who used perspective
to represent the plan explicitly as a
horizontal section previously buildings
had only been partly cut away in
vertical sections it should be noted
that despite the fact that it was
perspective which was so formative to
this significant change in the way the
plan was conceptualized it would only be
used by architects for a very short
period between the mid 15th century and
the early 16th when it was given up in
favor of orthographic projection
entirely meanwhile the obituaries and
section drawing from 3-dimensional
stereo stereo t'me continued and the
plan as section went unrecognized and we
can leap forward and see that
Corbusier's plan as generator
perpetuates this long-held habit of
segregating the uses of section
reinforcing the concealment of the logic
of sectioning inherent to the plan with
computer modeling what we have is not
the maturation but rather the
realization of a profound change that
occurred with the brief period of
perspective architectural space must
keep stacking however and it would seem
that until otherwise its levels will
still be accounted for in plans this not
to mention the fact that the plans still
hold sway at the drawing as the drawing
convention that correlates with the
navigation of architectural space
something that this section does not do
the vertical section that is the
computer has brought
about overall building forms such as
this one that do not extrude from
two-dimensional two-dimensional
originally plans at all
clearly the process has been reversed
entirely now we have three dimensional
forms full formed literally not only in
the imagination before we make plans and
so finally plans and sections are
literally results rather than origins
now there are buildings for which a plan
is not only not only not a generator but
is anatomical I called this type of plan
anatomical since it is like an
anatomical section it should be noted
that this extreme idea actually has as
one of its main progenitors this
building a pre computational building of
course and we find here the idea most
explicitly represented that the plan is
of no particular consequence and so far
as one would think of it as a generator
the plan instead is more like at any
point in this building a single frame in
a succession of frames and here for the
first time we have the analogy to the
filmic medium without extrusion we have
a continuously developing form of
architecture in which any plan
represents the principle of projective
sectioning finally and most
straightforwardly
which as we have seen superseded drawing
long ago with the arrival of respective
just to be clear though we are a very
long way of course from the time in the
early Renaissance before Raphael
when drawings who thought above all in
terms of plan would often find
themselves somewhat surprised by the
exteriors which resulted from their
plans now the building is in bottle
embodied fully a priori
with plans behaving as projective
sections in succession and in particular
with the skyscraper we recognize the
changed significance of extrusion if the
filmic medium becomes a more an apt
analogy for architectural representation
than pictorial perspective extrusion
assumes a new definition a new
definition exemplified most typically by
this modern skyscraper for extrusion to
produces a continuously developing form
but not with an and not with a changing
shape here we have a very interesting
moment where a building turns into a
very particular genre of film it may be
useful to take this analogy to an
extreme and understand that if the
Guggenheim is filmic it is conventional
narrative film continuously changing and
developing the form over time in a very
particular way but and very linearly but
if the extruded skyscraper plans our
slices too then then it is analogous to
non-narrative film and we could just now
make a parallel and this is a stretch
and a peculiar one to make but I think
useful for this argument two films like
those of Warhol and here we have sleep
in which the content is radically
reduced becoming secondary to a fixed
shape that is the figure almost not
changing fixed at least in the mind of
one who expects a narrative little
changing from frame to frame hours of
inactive sameness as opposed to
development Warhol encourages
distraction and wandering attention and
in this sense clearly has moved film
toward architecture it is interesting to
recognize that extrusion the most
typical formal attribute of modern
architecture
that is as it produces stacking perhaps
more than anything
owing to the elevator in the steel frame
which we continue to have to deal with
despite all of the fluidity that Patrick
seeks perhaps more than anything this is
what makes these radical avant-garde
films more analogous to architecture and
much more so than the rare anatomical
forms which despite being prevalent in
the Academy rare in the world that is
those which actually are closer to
conventional film those forms that are
today so popular than I'm referring to
you saw there the cutting plane of no
consequence moving through the tower
whereas of course in the Guggenheim we
saw a development occur now we have
something else and this is the
conclusion concluding point perhaps the
essential distinction between the
anatomical and extruded buildings both
which populate the imaginations of
Architects one way or the other whether
they like it or not the essential
distinction between them and their plans
is determined by the concept of duration
sleep demands the audience to endure the
unendurable boredom of sameness in a
medium that is expected to move and
develop conventional narrative film
precludes any recognition of the
Constituent frames that build its
movement between these two architectural
extremes the anatomical versus the
extruded or let's call it the narrative
versus the non narrative there is
another model the montage which makes
explicit the role of spatial successive
'no stand here until all of architecture
after the skyscraper as represented by
the plans that pile up and do not change
and thus analogizes the cutting and
that we've been talking about the
example of this in film of course the
best of all is Chris markers logit a a
dystopian narrative of time-travel which
is composed almost entirely of still
photographs it is essentially a photo
montage of stills variously pasted with
one brief motion picture segment it is a
series of sleeps the closest
architectural project to legit a is cool
houses of Karlsruhe center for art and
technology composed of discontinuous and
differentiated plans inside the rather
cubic building and plans populated
populated by the vertical struts of
viren deal trusses alternate with open
plans to produce a stack of spaces that
like an architectural montage evokes a
series of radically different
architectural types arguably the
architectural equivalent to time travel
this would include for example a kind of
proto hierarchical bizarre plan becoming
core du Chien a post-war me Chien plan
evacuated becoming bifurcated a stay
lost like plan a hypo style like plan my
favorite in the building and back to
Mies and thus we have here a building
that exemplifies of course his theory in
delirious New York we're piling the
slicing piling up caused is caused of
course as we know there by a culture he
calls congested only the extrusion of
the envelope maintains a constant that
holds the disparate interior plans
together just as linear sequence by
definition
unassailable technical support of the
filmic medium holds together the stills
of legit a as a tentative conclusion
recall that the concept of sectioning
and perspective projection once seemed
to be an advanced form of drawing but
for architecture projection now appears
to have been the harbinger of an era in
which the plan would be defined as one
of a series of successive slices through
the three-dimensional models and
structures that truly govern
architectural and spatial composition
that is after it's been thought that way
as far as architecture is concerned
therefore to the extent that the plan
remains important drawing has been dead
for all intents and purposes a lot
longer than the computer has been alive
thank you
thank you Scott our next speaker will be
Marian Weiss
Marian is co-founder of Weissman Freddy
architecture landscape urbanism a
multidisciplinary for him based in New
York City executing commissions
nationally and internationally her firm
has won numerous honors including the
American Academy of Arts and Letters
award the architectural League of New
York's emerging voices of North America
and the New York AIA chapters gold medal
throughout her career Weitz has taught
at numerous architectural schools
including those at Yale University
Cornell and since 1991 the University of
Pennsylvania Penn School of Design where
she is currently the grand professor in
architecture her work has been exhibited
extensively and many people in this room
may be familiar with her work with her
expressive charcoal renderings which
were among those exhibited in the 2010
Yale School of Architecture show an
architect's legacy James Stirling
students at Yale 1959 to 1983 here to
give a talk entitled vanishing points
Marian Weiss thank you George
and thank you Victor and thank you Bob
for convening this great discussion
about an obituary that has yet to be
written I think that the depictions and
descriptions of death are inevitably
there to elevate if you will the defense
of the subject of such speculation and
for me it's a luxury to actually
scrutinize this point really the
vanishing point of the intentionally
either/or query has drawing vanished has
the infinitely expanding capacity of the
digital paradigm displaced the efficacy
of all other media this question has a
parallel and it has a parallel with
painting and where the camera if you
will threaten the critical importance of
the somewhat imprecise media of the
canvass another either/or query that
proved to be more complex was this one
that said that oppositional
overstatement was exactly that so if the
camera raised this
the paintings obituary the painting of
the the potential painting expanded in
unexpected ways so if we think about the
fundamental nature of things that seem
to reassert themselves even when they're
they're sort of imminent design demise
as stated you would say that the if one
steps back a few centuries then we can
look at the Nazca lines here and look at
this incredible inscription on the land
and start to question about this desire
to mark the land a tactile resistant
surface with something that seems to
have a perspectival convergence that
suggests infinity and it's these two
points the tactility the convergence the
desire to shape a perception of owning
more land than you could possibly
imagine
in one point is where I want to step to
so if you see that if we look at the
vanishing point there was a moment where
was a very simple thing we all learned
how to do it in train tracks or the way
you can understand convergence but if we
step back a few centuries the
criticality of the vanishing point
eluded painters and by attempting to
subjects depth and distance the diagonal
line and the diaphanous backgrounds
implied the inhabitation of a territory
where buildings and landscapes were
infinitely larger than we could imagine
in one paper but the control of this
vanishing point if you will to
accurately depict depth and distance
aided the representation of architecture
and architects who were also painters
and set designers leveraged the
compressed space of the stage set to
suggest only not only infinite depth to
one vanishing point but perhaps to a few
multiple vanishing points so you could
say that the distortion necessitated a
precise location or station point of the
implicit picture plane to allow the
panoramic access to the multiple
vanishing points and the single
vanishing point with the converging
diagonals in the center shifted over
when the diagonal came into play to
something far more complex in fact you
could say that Alberti in 1435 had
advertised the perspective method in his
book on pain
and that how-to is extraordinarily
influential but perspective has been a
suspect tool and a critical voices of
the Renaissance while generating more
precision in the potential observed that
it was a deceitful practice always
distorting true measure so Piranesi was
a very skilled man in many ways but also
a skilled theatre designer among as many
talents and he took liberties with the
vanishing point and the act of drawing
actually inscribing an etching tool into
the surface of the metal again
resistance to suggest a more
indeterminate more simultaneously
ultimately incomprehensible territory of
infinite and inescapable depth his
etchings evolved in some cases with
additional layers of etching some
superimposed over the plate nearly 25
years after the initial first stage I
find this very interesting these
additional excavated layers subtracted
from the surface at an intensification
and additional elements a thickness and
tactile expression to the depth afforded
by perspective in fact the Pyrenees
effect of consciously created confusion
was more aspirational suggestive emotive
ultimately inconsistent and
unconstructive all projections but these
perspectives were never sedentary they
were in full motion providing incomplete
but compelling promise
now the impulse to represent the
infinite inhabitable potential of the
vanishing point was captured in the god
that everybody worshiped when I was in
school and continued to worship but you
could say that here he had a different
idea one where the vanishing point
wandered off on the horizon and it made
its way into some infinity which was
that drawn line again in the land but
finally thickened it inhabitable like a
contour so as a student here at Yale the
emphatic monumentality of the drawing
reflected the climate of the time
sterling and other modernists were
changing the way we're seeing things and
in the accident wreck summarizing the
totality buildings diagram an
idiosyncratic massing all at once was
the ultimate expression of invention and
control as students in Stirling studio
we understood the necessity of the fully
measureable impeccable inclined
organizational Authority the airily
disposed daksa metric or in this case a
schwa z view
and we knew that this be the necessary
pinnacle of our studio project I was
maybe a little more taken with the
building we were in by its kind of
sectional clarity and Rudolph's
incredible sectional perspective
drawings and so you could say that I was
not a good compliant student in Sterling
Studio because while it was easy to
emulate the accent of metric axiom I
felt a certain dissatisfaction in the
distance between the precision of the
ink drawing and the tactile impact and
in these certain boundaries of the
charcoal drawing and so I did my ink
drawings and I hated them every one of
them my project was fully measured and
so I returned and was reluctant
ultimately to commit to the precise line
because I didn't like the way it looked
I had not yet been able to arouse my own
enthusiasm with this accident metric
axiom and so the penalty of
procrastination were these drawings
which I was trying to get at something
that was not quite real not quite
they're not quite inhabitable but fully
inhabitable and simultaneous and somehow
momentum of territorial expansion was
something that I was trying to claim so
you could say that it was a challenge
because if you look at what it means to
start to think in more parametric terms
you could say the pre parametric which
Scott Cohen pointed out so eloquently
earlier with something that Michael
Manfredi and I because we draw together
and you'll see some in our presentation
that we've shared the idea of somehow
messing with or noodling with that
territorial clarity and crossing those
boundaries has been a preoccupation this
messiness or dirtiness is a point I want
to make Jasper Johns in 1979 talked
about how much you like to do a drawing
do it again and do it again in two
different media to see what he would
discover and every time he would
discover something different that
resistance would offer a new discovery
and sometimes that discovery would go to
white sometimes the numbers again and
again and again will become so
compelling to him that he had to make
tactile sculptures and surfaces some 25
years after those drawings were made not
unlike peering a Z returning to his
etchings creates something that's so
tactile immeasurable that it is indeed
physical almost architectural
so I taught a drawing class at Yale when
the parametric paradigm started in a
sense ascending and I wondered whether
it's possible to sustain the uncertainty
of the hand drawing and then the wet
meeting on plastic and then actually use
the computer to distort amplify
intensify and make new discoveries so by
using very simple drawings and
photographs those would then go into
another wet media on plastic which
Jasper John so loved and those could
then be intensified in digital terms to
be translated into things that might
sustain a more tactile kind of haptic
world or in fact actually become
something impossible to say the kind of
two-stage perspective that might start
to change over time when media gave it
new insights new light new amplification
and intensification so all this is to
say that these preoccupations of never
finding a finishing point to the
vanishing point gets to the surface of
our work and in our work for instance at
the Barnard College dianna Center while
we had a very spatial idea the diagonal
to connect and allow insights to be seen
simultaneously we also wanted to break
down the hard surface of a glass box and
consider the spatial connections that we
might see through that glass box in
conflated compress ways oblique ways but
that the surface itself was something
that we wanted to think about and so the
drawings are the sketches in charcoal
we love the indecision of them and the
indifference to the finish line and try
to sustain that indifference in the
surface of the glass so the Frick
pattern took the the sort of whisper of
the charcoal and then the acid etched
glass with about a year of
experimentation in Germany of externally
acid-etched internally color integral
spectrally selective glass that we
tested in different ways could actually
with the back pan four inches behind
that glass share the luminosity of
either red or copper depending on the
light and always change and never stay
fixed in chroma and so that kind of
collaboration there with the tactile
surface of the charcoal drawing and the
tactile thing then needed to be
analytically taken forward with the kind
of sectional sequential
connective identity that could change
connect bring forward and ultimately
take that notion that was indecisive at
one point and conclude with something
more precise so this exercise if you
will is under construction right now at
Penn with the nanotechnology building
that we're doing and there is a case it
wants immense precision because it is
indeed all about incredible stable
stabilization structurally and also no
electromagnetic interference so how do
you take the instability of the charcoal
drawing do you say the gesture of the
perfect concept plastic model the
indecision again of a cardboard model
the slightly more decisive discussion
with the client and then maybe the great
precision the parametric tools have
given us to actually realize something
that can move around allow us to
spatially create multiple vanishing
points and sequential movement under
construction now last week and start to
envision what it is to inhabit something
that makes you pull forward feel the
kind of tactility of these vanishing
points and imagine the kind of
transformation of a space that might
open up and shape a new landscape and if
you will inscribe its way onto an urban
surface and that inscription then with
the Museum of the earth in Ithaca New
York is now topographic and they're
itching and carving into the land and
the convergence if you will of
topographical and topological change is
tied to the kind of experiential first
impulse collages that then allow us to
start to imagine what it is to take
those things more precisely into the
earth again sequentially sectionally
moving and starting to look at the
gathering of water and the bridges of
something that might collect water to
then take that Nazca line again and to
make that site look substantially larger
while it's doing an operation that
collects water and it habits the site in
a completely different way and this in
habitation than currently under
construction that botanic garden
Brooklyn Botanic Garden is something
again where the idea of Olmsted's
wandering paths and the idea of a kind
of softened topography were these
instincts that we had when we thought
about the city
entry into the garden but then there's a
kind of wild sketch of what happens when
you sort of say all right we've got
parking on one side we've got moving
we've got security we've got topography
about section we've got water collection
we've got all these things and then the
distillation of these things has to go
through a rubric of sequential sections
that change and go from urban to
something that actually just joins the
land and so these kind of lose toggling
between wandering lines and wandering
lines again or the inhabitation of the
edge of the garden or maybe too distant
vanishing points on either side or in a
hable do POG Rafi that might be softer
and surface than what the parametric
steel plan and allowed us to do could be
so soft in fact that maybe the
sensuality that sketch line and the
topical surface of the charcoal drawing
could come together so in Seattle this
question then of what it might mean to
just collage a new topography onto the
city and again that rough anger of oh my
god it has to do everything all at once
remediation speed movements
sectionalization salmon habitat surfaces
for art etc all those layers need to be
analytically totally organizationally
including you know contamination
remediation have to be thought of in
layers sexually topically organized and
so we're always thinking about this kind
of cinematic potential of lateral
contours and vertical sections
simultaneously being conceived to allow
us to see things in ways that would
allow us to imagine a constructed
topographic land form that could
ultimately connect to disparate parts of
the city so a kind of strange conflation
then of sketching thinking in section
and sectional perspective to the making
of this kind of convergent line these
kind of angles trying to enlarge a site
that's actually tiny only nine acres and
all these kinds of diagonals and
allowing and embrace simultaneous of
roads going through it under it over it
across on the horizon and this kind of
mix of media simultaneously in our
thinking has been the kind of cast if
you will of our preoccupation
with the kind of layered intensification
and aggregation if you will or
condensation of a bigger world like a
theatrical world one very finite place
and so this sort of sense of movement
and movement again is what I'll invoke
in this kind of closing animation that
will follow this the sense of movement
simultaneity multiple sort of theatrical
sets that we might get two leads to a
fiction that if we could start the
animation just now I'll close with a few
observations if indeed the animation is
animated
so I guess it's that dirty secret if you
will it's the native potential of
different media the intensification if
you will from repetition from doing it
again
trying it again and doing these
superimpositions to intensify through
repetition etc the potential of
something sort of irritating little
point about what it might be and so all
these combining of tools the kind of
distortions the effects the surfaces the
potentials the movement the cinematic
all of this in a sense suggests to me
that it's a fictional finish line to say
that drawing is dead but somehow the
iterations scenarios and options from
the charcoal sketch to the digital
frameworks to the surface effects that
somehow the back and forth of these
medias including digital media allows an
approximation that allows us to postpone
conclusions but to somehow enrich our
process along the way and so if we say
that the kind of softened decision of
the material that charcoal for instance
could change this building's thinking
from a hard glass into something else we
could say that even with Seattle then
the real vanishing point starts to touch
on this issue of the premature obituary
that I think has been read for this
conference because if the point of an
obituary is to summarize in short order
the virtues contributions and the impact
of an individual that is suddenly gone
usually usually the glowing setting
aside of the weaker moments is what is
what obituaries do and they have a
curatorial II polished if you will
selection of milestones to let us know
what was great but what is gone but for
us the promise now with the glow of the
padishah digital paradigm if you will
casting shadows over six centuries of
drawing is not saying that it's over but
in fact is giving us a moment to
leverage the opportunity of the
simultaneity and the capacities of all
these medias somehow to draw out what is
yet to be imagined so I like to say then
that my final point
the vanishing point if you will is that
there is no death to drawing but there
is only maybe infinite richness in that
vanishing point that's beyond us and
that in this framework of media in
motion testing sequentially that somehow
all of us have yet to draw something
that we have yet to see thank you
thank you for a wonderful talk Marian
our next speaker has asked me to abandon
the the introduction that I was going to
give him which which I will do but I
must say that probably familiar to all
of you Greg Lynn his work has has been
recognized as pioneering in the world of
digital drawing we are lucky to have him
at the Yale School of Architecture where
he serves as Davenport professor and
without further ado Greg Lynn you can
leave the lights up for a second
well first I'm a little embarrassed
because I actually brought drawings and
the drawings that I'm gonna show you
were not meant for you to ever see they
were really just for me
but I thought it would be interesting so
indulge me they certainly aren't as
beautiful as a lot of the drawings we've
seen today but I do have a few comments
before I talk about some technical
issues with drawing I think the first
thing is I would like to make a
statement that I don't believe I can
substantiate but it's that there's a
difference not between drawing and
computation but I'd say there's a
difference between drawing and drafting
and I don't know quite where sketching
falls into all that but I actually
believe that that drawing is associated
with the critical development of a
project with a critical attitude towards
a project and a design approach and it
usually precedes drafting so innovations
in drafting will follow innovations in
drawing but I believe that spatially
anyway the way I think is through
drawing and drafting is always tracking
it I mean drafting is important because
it's descriptive which I think Scott
talked a lot about the descriptive power
of it
it also can involve expediency accuracy
I mean Andrew had some awesome comment
- Ella T of 3d models I mean I think
these are all things that I associate
with drafting and mechanical procedures
now the reason I'm trying to make this
distinction is is I believe that in this
parametric moment that there's a drawing
attitude and an optimization and a
freedom of of managing complexity but I
also believe there's a drawing component
to it that's very important so I
wouldn't make any distinctions in its
scale or precision or even technical
method or media between these things but
I think the distinction is important so
the the real difference is this creative
versus let's say managerial quality now
the reason I'm saying this is I'd be a
little trouble if we left today with the
distinction between sketching as a
conceptual and creative act and
computation as implementation of that or
a management of that I think for me the
the digital medium is much more
important than that
I know that the sketch the pencil sketch
or the pen sketch everybody was kind of
proudly holding up their pencils and
pens yesterday it it signifies an area
of expertise I think I could probably
hold up a mouse and say that I you know
use my hand on a mouse instead of a
pencil in a way that it also cuts to the
point I mean I was watching Julie's
presentation today which was amazing but
I was thinking to myself oh my god I
would have to spend like two weeks
learning how to use that sketch program
that's like so cumbersome compared to
how I sketch with a computer already so
and I'll show some examples of that so
anyway the other thing I'd like to say
is that there is a disruption in any
field especially design fields but in
really any field manufacture
during all kinds of fields when a new
technology comes in to the discipline
the previous knowledge the habits the
methods that made up intuition critical
intuition and intelligence have to be
rethought when these new technologies
come in doesn't mean that they replace
them it just means you have to adapt and
define a new medium and I think really
where we are now is at the point that we
can maturely claim that digital
technology as a medium it's probably the
first time it's been I've been using it
maybe 25 30 years but I think now is the
time it's a medium that's why we're
having a conference on drawing and
digital technology as a kind of subtext
to that so it's a continual process of
the introduction of tools but digital
design and manufacturing talking to
machines constitutes a pretty radical
rethinking of our drawing medium today
so geometry maybe has changed but I
really believe that the medium by which
we describe these geometries has has
radically changed so this excitement
about new potential which I had 20 years
ago I realized pretty quickly there is a
down side to it which is everybody in
the field becomes an amateur like the
minute the new technology comes in we
all don't know what we're doing anymore
and you used to hear a lot of words like
experimental digital design and things
which was just an example of the fact
that nobody knew what they were doing
I've used this example of the Ford
Taurus when Lee Iacocca said they were
gonna do he called it no more over the
fence design meaning the designers would
throw a design over the fence to the
engineers but that they would try to
compress the design process from six
years to two by having everybody used
computers and what happened with the
Ford Taurus was it was the second
generation Taurus was the first car to
be designed with surface software and
the poor designers didn't know how to
put a door handle on it rear view
mirrors was a blob they called it a blob
what was most alarming to me was that
critics that cultural critics and
theorists took the tourist and turned it
into a design icon as if this kind of
barely articulated blob of a car
designed by amateurs was the future of
design and the reason they did that is
because they didn't understand what was
going on so what's more troubling to me
than the loss of facility that comes
with new technology is the loss of
critical and theoretical knowledge in
the institutions that are training these
people so I mean nobody acknowledged
that we were a bunch of amateurs 10 20
years ago and what I found is that
journalists and cultural critics and
even historians and theorists are too
quick to apply old standards to these
new mediums and new technologies that
generates a lot of confusion so the
amateur ization of a field by taking
away its facility with drawing tools and
replacing it with new tools set
something up where the critical
community is that always tracking and
behind the designers rather than leading
them and I think that's something I've
witnessed today to be totally Frank I
mean I was knocked out by Andrew Witt
who I thought was the chief technology
officer but is the director of research
for a computer company gave the most
profound historical and theoretical talk
of the day and the historians and
theorists I'm sure weren't aware of any
of that stuff
so it's really shocking to me the gap
between the designers and the historians
and theorists and for me I think the
task isn't so much rethinking drawing
it's rethinking the history and theory
of drawing so in anecdotally Antoine
Picone said to me you know it's funny
all the phd's that do their
dissertations on drawing never complete
so it's something for the historians and
theorists to think about so the
disappearance of critical journals
theorists and critics from our field and
and
a loss I think of discourse coincides
with this introduction of digital media
and I think it's just a fact of our
field and needs to get fixed rapidly
okay so to kind of get to the silly
anecdotes and drawings which I'm trying
to avoid showing you I think instead of
saying that that drawing is dead because
of loss of the sketch what I'd like to
do is show a couple of examples of how
I'd like to use digital technology the
same way I use pen and ink drawings or
constructed drawings I brought stuff
from 20 over 25 years ago to show you I
think that I'm doing this to show two
things the first is that there's an
anticipation of the computer in drawings
that made the computer happen and I
actually believe and this is just
because it's my personal experience that
it was the New York 5 that generated the
need for the computer the approach to
form as well as a kind of palladianism
espoused by Colin Rowe was that I don't
know I feel free to leave the room for
the next half hour what what you need to
know is I always am holding my hand up
saying I'm a student of Michael's he
still hasn't claimed me yet but we'll
see but anyway I believe the New York 5
and the education that I got under and
being mentored by members of the New
York 5 was really what was pointing me
towards digital technology and I think
digital technology didn't just happen
contrary to yesterday's comments it was
actually developed by the architects and
it was developed to satisfy a need that
was already being anticipated so that's
the first point I'd like to make the
second is that I think there's an
assumption that you can't sketch with
digital technology or that it's so
cumbersome and
curat that it takes a long time to
sketch and I'll show you some examples
of you know quick sketching with the
computer but what's funny is when I draw
with a pen it's always something I do
after I've sketched with the computer to
kind of clarify it and simplify it and
frankly it takes me a lot longer like I
can model something much quicker than
when I draw it to clarify it I'll show
you some examples of that so I guess I
only can dim the lights okay I don't
know why this would probably be for an
analyst to figure out I've always hated
these things though just because they're
so flaccid it's it it's also impossible
to get wall thickness with these things
so I actually went to Princeton to learn
how to draw these I mean this is a thing
that I whipped up actually on the way
over here but it's a composite curve
network which is made out of a series of
radii and what's the reason I wanted to
learn how to draw it is because you can
offset wall thickness with it whereas if
you use one of these things it's a
nightmare and it's very inaccurate so I
was very and you can also change regions
of a curve network like this without
having to change the whole thing
which you can't do with a French curve
or you can't do as a flexible curve so I
went to Princeton because I knew Michael
did decide Herman house and I wanted to
learn how to draw those curves up there
in the Sneiderman house and what's funny
is when I got there I found one of these
mechanical splines there was a German
student who I don't remember who is two
years older than I was who had one of
these things and it's this is 25 years
old so I had three of them I tried to
unroll one to take a picture it fell
apart but there's a rubber profile with
all of these discs it's a very old
drafting device and it's called a spline
and you draft coordinates for the disks
and tape the disks down and you can make
a
wine curved and it comes from the
shipbuilding industry but civil
engineers we're using them like crazy I
got to Princeton and found these I don't
even know if Michael remembers but it
was like a virus
all the students had these by the time I
graduated what was interesting about it
is it turns a curve into a series of
infinitesimal line segments rather than
being arcs they're all little short
straight lines that are just smooth with
the spline curve after Princeton I went
to work for Peter Iseman and Peter at
that time was doing curvature without
curves this is something for Peters
analyst probably but I spend you know
you can see these are I believe I mean
I'm haunted by it I think a hundred and
thirty blocks that are rotated in plan
and section three stacks high also the
Frankfurt bio centrum which came before
this did a very similar thing with
arraying profiled elements along curves
but without actually using curves at
this time there was software to array
these things there really wasn't
software to work fluidly with those
elements but but one of the things I
discovered with this ability to make
curves out of incremental line segments
which is what a spline is is that
there's a curve and there's the normal
which is the the line that's
perpendicular to the tangency of this
virtual curve when I left Peter's office
now their anecdote
don't let Bob Somel pick you an
apartment in Chicago he found me an
apartment in a building which I found
out was for blind people so I was in
this little room it's a kind of Burton
think era of my life and I spent maybe a
day building this model of the Sears
Tower laid down for a show Stanley Tiger
Minh was doing
and then I spent three months maybe 12
hours a day drafting all 110 floors of
the Sears Tower
first rotated in plan and then projected
in section and rotated in section and
then projected back into the plan and
rotated in plan and then back to the
section again there's nine of these
tubes but so I I produce these drawings
over you know incredible amount of labor
to then use MicroStation which was the
first program that had spline modeling
tools a couple years later I did this
whole operation and maybe 15 or 20
minutes by just animating blocks along
paths so I think you know I'm one of the
I think I'm the oldest person that
models with the computer I believe I've
been looking around to find somebody old
or least who's been doing it longer so
I'm like a t-rex but anyway these things
you know that I'm glad I did this I
wouldn't have thought you know every day
when I animate something along a path I
actually remember the labor involved in
not doing it but I also understand the
principles and the projective geometry
of doing it anyway but so this idea of
incremental sweeps and animations this
was also for a competition for
cabrini-green where I manually drafted
each one of these elements moving with
an adjustable triangle so I mean
obviously I was waiting for the computer
to be able to do this for me but before
there was a program for me to use I was
already thinking of this kind of I mean
now you would call it you know an array
you know but incremental change in
gradient but so it's just to make the
point all of this stuff was being
anticipated before it had arrived it's
not like it arrived with a shock it kind
of was a welcome thing for me I'll show
some more examples these kind of brain
diagrams were also these are drafted
this was for the Cardiff Bay Opera House
competition I don't actually remember
the date of that but this was a thing
where I was just branching these based
on a thing called Bateson's rule and
changing the scale with every iteration
and branching and you'd now call it some
kind of procedural modeling as well I
mean now if you use subdivision surfaces
and things you're using a algorithm by
Chaiken that smooths corners but at the
same time I had this idea where the
volumes when they were small would be
less have less resolution like
four-sided and I would not corners off
of these things every time they got
bigger and bigger and bigger so and then
after the competition so these were all
manually drafted using those branching
rules and the smoothing rules and
drafted in section as well and then
maybe a year after the project was done
we actually modeled it on the computer
but again all these operations are
operations that now we understand as
being part of digital technology but
really were anticipated before it had
ever arrived
that's the rendering of it okay now I
think once this software was available I
started to sketch with it and sketching
with the computer at first was you know
it involved learning the medium but
actually I've never found it not to be
expedient I mean not to be as expedient
as a pen or a pencil these were real
early studies with a blob modeler from a
program called wavefront that we used
with Doug and Mike for the Korean
Presbyterian Church and the logic of the
model you know here which were very kind
of randomly placed you know ended up
following the rhythm of the structure of
the building
ended up you know kind of informing the
way that it was modeled as a surface
with these offset planes you know and
fairly directly went into the logic of
the construction but again you know the
this was a project was which was
sketched entirely digitally I mean I we
don't really have any hand sketches of
this project and I have to say for a
long time I quit doing a lot of drawings
this was maybe the first drawing I could
find which was I think three two or
three years later which was a little
diagram for the arc of the world in
Costa Rica this Visitor Center and it
was trying to work out an idea of
losting or there was one set of curves
in this direction that you'd call a path
and another set of curves that were
profiles and you can see these profiles
are just I actually animated the profile
and then swept that animated profile
along that path there you get a massing
like this but in this case it was really
a sketch that came before the the
massing and and more and more I started
doing sketching and what I found is that
I was kind of sketching for the computer
like the what I was drawing was really
drawing the way things would get modeled
and even putting little dimensional
notes the way things would get modeled
and again these things have not really
for like popular consumption there are
more things to either that really
defects back to the office but just
should clarify things this was a funny
little anomaly I found I turned off
these things called curve loop cutting
the surfaces were folding through
themselves and making some problems I
turned off this tool and found these
things that industrial designers we're
calling blebs but it's where offset
spline where you offset thickness for a
spline it folds through itself and for
the i-beam museum I use this as a kind
of facade idea to take the skin and fold
these cantilever
exhibition space is out to the street
and then fold the auditorium into the
facade and fold the lobby out to the
street and you could see these little
diagrams were before it is a little bit
during the modeling but it was to
clarify the the massing but anyway these
started to look more like things from
the computer these are the kind of
controlling curves of the skin than just
some very quick renderings of it a
little study model you know was also
around this time that I bought a laser
cutter and a CNC mill and did again what
Andrew started what he mentioned which
was machine legible design I thought
high fidelity machine legible design
that if you don't mind I'd like that to
be my new moniker but so I then started
to think through how to talk to machines
that are fabricating construction
elements so for this little study for a
house which I remember I did at the
conference for Michael's retirement at
Princeton while how fast I was speaking
I remember I was sitting in the audience
that did this little doodle for a
structure because I didn't have a
computer near me but the idea was that
the structure of the house is built out
of one continuous rolled tube that would
float the house I just seen the Lina Bo
Bardi house and from this diagram went
directly working with Robert a ship
MicroStation with building a little
parametric tool that again would build
all these tubes as composite curves
because they needed to be radial curves
so instead of drawing a spline and
converting it to a radii these start
with the radii and you can see you can
move elements around they automatically
there you could see this composite curve
drawing
okay the the other kind of drawing tool
that that I find very powerful and
useful our expression tools really
they're the basis of of what now people
call parametric modeling I started using
them from tools that were built into CAD
software for animators to try to attract
animators to digital technology for this
Alessi coffee set you can see there's a
series of nine eight or nine curves
which I just designed for how you'd grip
the pot and then by combining those nine
curves in four positions we came up with
you know tens of thousands of options
for the flatware for Alessi very similar
approach I've shown this before here so
I'll just show it real quick I designed
a primitive which could be a fork a
spoon or a knife and then gave it traits
and used animation software to blend
between these different traits here's
some of that flatware as it's produced
but again you start with the primitive
and you variate but for me the ability
to sketch these forms using animation
tools is what was important and then
finally for me a logic of surface
minimalism let's say which I now know is
gonna be very big with your occipital
temporal lobes but what it is is it
it's a logic of using spline surfaces to
integrate components and parts it really
started with products this is a little
sketch the very first sketch I did for
the ravioli chair with the idea that
there's a hard surface that does
everything that legs and a base would do
and there's a soft top surface that does
everything that the arms and the seat
and a back would do so you'd really
integrate all these components into two
spline surfaces
it would take care of all this one hard
one soft that's the finished chair the
Alessi supple cups I mean this is really
where it's I'm drawing for computer
modeling but you know at container to
keep liquid hot and then ask in second
skin which you grip and all of these
points are kind of defining the limits
of splines and how they would vary and
get lofted to produce these volumes
what's very funny is I hadn't even
looked this is like the worst drawing I
ever did so move in but the first model
I did for the bloom house was actually
this set of five surfaces that were very
quickly lofted I believe this whole
process I looked at the times and dates
of the file but these are ten minute
sketches they're really very quick
little sketches to kind of get the
massing on the site and see options
there were four or five but this is
closest to the finished house where
there's this kind of open corner this
top surface and bottom surface bite
together to form these kind of eye
shapes you know this open front with
this hanging Lantern I mean it's very
funny it was kind of all there nascent
Lee in a little ten minute digital
sketch that then we could quickly render
and it was really the diagrams and the
drawings that had to catch up to that
and sorry to just jump but I mean you
can see that a lot of the basic moves
you know that corner were there in that
very first digital sketch which is where
the first idea is for the house came up
and this is that kind of surface
minimalism this is that thing that part
of your brain would love because there's
no fireplace sitting there there's just
a space that swallows the fireplace same
with the bathrooms toilets and sinks and
everything all get kind of absorbed into
this wet wall
okay very last thing the what I'm
playing around with now are these
coplanar details where two materials
occupy the same surface and get
laminated up into these sandwiches and
this is something just to show you don't
know how to sketch yet but go very
quickly too with the you know computer
models the future I believe I mean the
thing what's happened to me I remember
with the Port Authority project which
was the first animation sketched thing I
ever did I had to set up something in
the computer hit enter and wait 12 hours
for it to give me a result and I haven't
had that experience for a while and I
started using computational fluid
dynamics because I'm interested in the
design of moving objects and not only
the fact that you design these things in
a fluid and shape them in a fluid but
also that when they sit still they have
to look like they're moving and there's
a naval architect who now is working in
my office full-time and the two of us
have been playing around with using this
computational fluid dynamics and this is
something where we send a file to a 60
computer cluster and it takes seven days
to give us something back once we have
it back we can visualize it and move it
around and look at it but it's really
really slow but all I can say is that
when it gets real time which it'll do
very soon really changes the way you
think about space because you're
designing in a space which is active
this is a trimaran
that we're just starting construction on
you can see it's it's actually the first
object that's ever been modeled in both
air and water at the same time
and the one example I'll show of how
this modeling in a fluid dynamic space
has changed the way we design first is I
don't know that much about boats but I
just do stuff and we put it in the
machine and see what the consequences
are I mean the naval architect has an
intuition about it but so what this boat
wants to do because it goes 25 or 30
miles an hour all the time as it wants
to flip over end over end and bury its
nose so one of the things we did as we
get back images like this this is what's
called flow separation which is a bad
thing we try to minimize that with
styling and the surfaces but I came up
with this shine and this fold and the
bow it turns out what it dives this
helps it to lift back up out of the
water again so what's great about this
is you're putting forms into an analytic
matrix of flow you can experiment like
an amateur but it gives you back
performance information and it really
changes the space you're sketching in
because for the first time the space
you're sketching in is actually moving
with force and direction which for me is
the most exciting thing I've ever come
across with a computer after 20 or so
years and this company that's doing this
work actually primarily focuses on super
tall buildings so they're already deep
in the architecture world so thanks very
much